and they're all now they're all
condemning the former president the
former administration they're all
running as quickly as they can away oh
it's so good to be in an administration
now that believes in science
and lets these these technocrats do
whatever they want
fatchi is not the only one jerome adams
who is the former surgeon general under
president trump
he is coming out now and
begging the liberal elite and the
establishment and the media
for forgiveness for committing the
heinous crime of
working as the surgeon general in the
trump administration and that is
really pitiful i feel he seems like a
nice enough guy i mean he's an
impressive guy in his own right isn't he
an admiral his
surgeon general but it's pathetic what
he's reduced himself to
and and the way in which he's begging
forgiveness is even more pathetic
jerome adams writes quote people so
freely suggest they would have left
the trump administration but hold the
one woman in the room to a different
standard
if dr burks or i weren't there many
medical
public health conversations would have
had no input whatsoever
from a woman or a person of color that's
a heavy
cross to bear are you kidding me
let me ask you i'm going to try to make
this point in a
the least provocative way i can because
i know we're living in a very
politically correct culture
what is the benefit to the study of a
virus in the implementation of
policies that will slow the spread of
the virus what is the benefit
in and of itself of having a woman or a
person of color
give that opinion what is what what
medical and scientific benefit is
derived
from dr burke's genitals or jerome
adams's skin color
that uniquely qualified him to give
advice on the virus
first of all as far as i can tell that
entire team
of genius technocrat virus experts
of all colors and all sexes completely
botched the public health messaging the
one thing they got right was
how quickly they got the vaccine out
everything else they completely screwed
up
so not a big recommendation but how
pathetic this guy jerome adams is a real
guy
admiral career of military service
uh rose to the highest level of his
profession
in the government surgeon general of the
united states and the
the best thing he can say to recommend
himself is the color of his skin
what a bizarre world we're living in
that that's the case
why on earth does this have to be a race
thing
because race in particular but sex also
in all of these various identity groups
has become
a national obsession it's and
it's used by the left in a very
destructive way
and it was developed over the course of
at least 100 years and this actually
part of my new book that's coming out
pretty soon speechless
controlling words controlling minds just
a little plug in there you can pre-order
it but it's not going to be out for a
few months
this was developed intentionally by the
left as a means of
subverting the traditional standards and
getting all americans to hate one
another
and implementing their their agenda but
it's not just the left
conservatives buy into this identity
politics stuff too
they are they are so afraid of being
called a sexist or a racist or
this phobe or that phobe that they play
into this sort of thing and i don't
think it's respectful
i think what jerome adams is saying here
is is so
debasing he's so degrading himself by
stooping to this level
by first of all by apologizing for
serving a surgeon general
and then under the mean orange man and
then
defending it on the race card
or defending berks on the sex card
that's pathetic unfortunately though
conservatives play into this sometimes
too and it gets to one of the great
national debates of the last six hours
that seems trivial but actually i think
is important we are having the latest
stage
of a debate that has raged for years and
years at this point
over whether or not we should replace
andrew jackson on the 20
bill i know this debate seems
trivial most people say who cares
the left cares because they've been
pushing this for a long time
the left cares a lot and maybe there's a
reason for that
you know the left cares a lot about
these things that seem kind of small
like
for instance gendered bathrooms right
the idea that
men have to use the men's room and women
have to use the women's room they say i
want someone men to be able to use the
women's room and
what a lot of conservatives say oh who
cares well the left cares
and their care about it is not frivolous
they realize
that in this symbol this sort of
in itself a relatively minor act they
can get a whole lot more of their
political premises across
that's what we're seeing here the the
proposal is to replace andrew jackson on
the 20
bill with harriet tubman harriet tubman
the slave
who escaped and got lots of other slaves
to
to be freed as well developed the
underground railroad
supported john brown who was the great
abolitionist
and so therefore we should put her on
the 20 bill
i'm against this idea i'm not against
this idea because i don't like harriet
tubman harriet tubman is a very
admirable american
i'm against this idea because
of the political message that
the left is trying to push with it and
that conservatives are acquiescing to i
would say most conservatives i know
are for replacing andrew jackson on the
20 bill with harriet tubman specifically
and the argument usually goes something
like this they say
well andrew jackson's the founder of the
democratic party
and harriet tubman's a gun-toting
republican so yeah fine by me folks
that's okay
that's kind of what you hear in the
general
kind of conservative blue check mark
sphere
however you'll notice that the people
who are actually pushing this not the
people who are acquiescing to it but the
people who are pushing this
are democrats and the people who have
resisted it
are republicans president trump slowed
this process down for four years
it was supposed to happen four years ago
he put the kibosh on it now it seems to
be speeding up again
so why is that why is it that the
democrats are pushing the gun-toting
republican
and the republican is defending the
founder of the democratic party
well what people will tell you
usually leftists but i suppose some
conservatives do will tell you is the
reason
that p anyone would oppose this idea is
because you're a racist
because you don't want black people on
money that's why
right and there it is there there it is
and i think a lot of the reason that
republicans
are so quick to jump out and say no i'm
for it i think it's great it's because
they
they're doing the thing that republicans
always do which is trying to prove to
the left that we're not racists uh which
is a fool's errand because the left
first of all the left
harbors much more racial bigotry than
the right does
i think that's without question at this
point they're instituting legal
racial discrimination on the left uh but
also the left doesn't care they don't
care that we're not racist or bigots or
whatever it's just
they're just using it as a cudgel we're
not uh you know bigoted but
that's sort of beside the point we're
talking about this issue here
i think what the move to to put tubman
on the bill is for
is largely to get rid of andrew jackson
andrew jackson has been much maligned in
this country
over the past couple of decades and
republicans have gone along with it
you know sort of cynically they want to
prove they're not racists i think but
also because
uh he's the founder of the democratic
party andrew jackson is a great american
he was a hero of new orleans
he was an important president he was a
good american leader
he had many flaws as do we all
and and great men have great flaws but
the the attack on andrew jackson is a
way to attack
our traditions and our founding fathers
and all the great men that we've revered
they always go for the easy ones first
they all they always ban alex jones from
the internet
before they ban donald trump right they
they want to ban the guys that nobody's
going to defend
and then they ramp it up and then they
ramp it up and then they ramp it up and
then they go for the sitting president
of the united states and whole
scores of mainstream conservatives it's
the same thing with historical figures
first they go for robert e lee what are
you some kind of confederate what are
you some kind of racist
and conservatives who who understand
what this game is about say
wait a second it's not about robert lee
they're going to go after
washington they're going to go after
jefferson remember trump said that in a
speech
and the left says no that's not true and
then the squishy republicans say no
that's not true lee's terrible he's all
we got to get rid of lee
and then two seconds later they're
toppling statues of washington they're
erasing his name
from buildings they're getting rid of
jefferson they're getting rid of
because there's no end to it so sure we
get this little victory yeah we topple
the
leader of the founder of the democratic
party okay they're coming for all of
them too
and it's based on this idea by the way
that is
identity politics i think harriet tubman
could deserve
i mean she's been honored in many ways
in this country but sure put her on some
denomination or something put her on
some money
make up a coin like they did for
sacagawea give harriet tubman some money
that's fine
it wouldn't be enough because it's about
replacing andrew jackson and i think
harriet tubman is being used here
because of her sex and even more so
because of her race
if this is really just about putting an
abolitionist on money why wouldn't we
put john brown on the money
why not replace andrew jackson with john
brown harriet tubman herself
greatly admire john brown said that john
brown in his death
did more than a hundred men could living
harriet tubman aided john brown not in
the actual raid on harper's ferry for
which he was most famous
because she was either recovering from a
sickness or whatever she was she
couldn't be found at that point but she
did aid him quite a lot so why not john
brent well john brown's a white guy
i mean the people who are pushing this
are they don't care about harriet tubman
they just care about identity politics
and and we give in on this because we
all like harriet tubman
but we're giving them this premise
when we replace a great american andrew
jackson
when we fail to defend more broadly our
american tradition
don't do it don't fall for it it's a
trick i mean i i
get why political correctness has
succeeded i get why the left has
been so successful on the cultural front
for the last 50 years certainly and
really for the last hundred years
because it's so subtle it's so hard to
defend but i think
i think we should speaking of these
sorts of putting people
of various backgrounds on money i should
remind you by the way it's not as though
we don't have
women of color on money sacagawea i just
mentioned we had pocahontas on money as
early as 1865.
we had her on banknotes as early as 1865
not
uh not elizabeth warren who would not be
a woman of color but
but the actual pocahontas i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you